[Music]
the highly anticipated second trailer
for captain marvel gave fans a closer
look at brie larson as carol danvers
and her fabulous occasionally mohawk
superhero alter ego
captain marvel even more eye-patchless
nick fury and teased an awesome looking
space battle sequence
there was a lot to love in the newest
sneak peek but one clip does a bit more
heavy lifting than the rest solving a
minor
mcu mystery we know that captain marvel
tells carol danvers origin story and to
do that without making even more of a
mess out of the existing marvel
cinematic universe timeline
directors anna fleck and ryan bowden are
rolling the clock back
23 years and introducing the hero in
1995.
it's an exciting choice but it was also
somewhat confusing since carol danvers
is also lined up to appear in avengers 4
which is set in the here and now if
captain marvel is set more than 20 years
prior to the events of the infinity war
sequel
wouldn't that mean she would be
middle-aged by the time she shows up in
the forthcoming film
and if she isn't pushing 50 in avengers
4 and does appear in the film in the
same youthful form that she does in her
solo movie
which is the most likely outcome does
that signal time travel is to thank for
her involvement
that doesn't appear to be the case the
newest trailer appears to reveal the
real reason for carol's perpetually
youthful appearance
it's the result of the accident that
left her human body imbued with dna from
the alien race known as the cree
first introduced in the mcu and agents
of shield and guardians of the galaxy
in the trailer we see annette benning
appear as an unnamed mystery character
who explains to carol her cree
origins telling her that the cree
rescued her when she was in trouble and
couldn't remember who she was
we made you one of us
so you could live longer stronger
superior to the average watcher those
lines might not hold much weight
yeah of course captain marvel is
physically powerful and superior to
humans whose dna
isn't comprised of half cree genetics
that's the kind of stuff that makes
superheroes superheroes
but this clip implies that carol will
outlive regular humans and will age at a
significantly slower rate
perhaps explaining why she will barely
have gotten any older between the time
of her accident in captain marvel
and when she heads back to earth in
avengers 4. marvel die hards probably
already knew all of this
agents of shield just for one example
addresses the phenomenal longevity of
the cree
but more casual marvel moviegoers were
likely confused before this revelation
someone who will feel the effects of
time however is nick fury
marvel digitally de-aged samuel l
jackson's character for the entirety of
captain marvel
but he'll be his old self again
literally in time for avengers 4.
by the time nick pages carol for backup
and the post-credits scene in infinity
war
he's sporting some wrinkles and his
signature patch over his eye
even with this plot hole clearing
there's still much about captain marvel
fans have yet to discover
like what's up with goose the cat is
pulp fiction available at that
blockbuster making this a last action
hero situation
no it isn't possible what's not possible
he's fantastic who is annette benning
plane and will she ever run into michael
douglas in the mcu giving american
president fans a reunion they crave
does carol smack down any other
suspicious septuagenarians or just
subway lady
so many questions the good news is that
fans won't have to wait too much longer
for answers
captain marvel soars into theaters on
march 8 2019